[Música]
pues primero que todo quiero agradecer
al colegio colombiano por la invitación
esto ha sido un año de desafíos para
todos entre esos organizar este evento
así que a carolina ya todo el equipo
felicitaciones por finalmente llegar a
este punto y para mí por supuesto es un
honor estar acá he querido hablar un
poco sobre educación y por eso el título
de esta charla a la arquitectura como el
tercer profesor
iniciaré básicamente mencionando que
nuestro equipo de trabajo aparte de
marcela y yo somos un equipo de gente
muy joven casi tan jóvenes como los
estudiantes del colegio anglo en sus
últimos años porque nos interesa mucho
trabajar con equipos de gente joven y
talentosa y esa es parte de nuestro adn
y otro tema que es importante mencionar
es tiene que ver con el aspecto de cómo
es y qué es la arquitectura y resulta
que la arquitectura justo en este
gráfico lo que muestra es que estamos en
la mitad entre lo científico y lo
creativo y lo científico porque un
edificio necesita aguantar su peso
aguantar un sismo evitar que el agua
entre etcétera y lo creativo porque el
edificio finalmente lo que hace es
transmitir al ser humano una mejor forma
de vivir entonces siempre estamos como
en ese dilema si somos
por un lado artistas o si somos por otro
lado científicos y eso es parte del adn
y van a ver un poco más adelante porque
me refiero a esto entonces en los temas
de educación
la idea de enseñanza-aprendizaje
finalmente el ser humano es eso somos el
producto de un aprendizaje a través del
tiempo
y este ser humano primitivo que poco a
poco se fue convirtiendo en homo sapiens
e inclusive aquí donde estamos se
convirtió en el hombre anglos
colombianos
y esto finalmente nos hace diferentes
nos hace especiales y nos llena de
compromisos entonces dentro de eso ese
sistema donde nos educamos que digamos
me referiré especialmente a los colegios
está sobre todo quiénes son y cuáles son
los roles de los que de las personas que
intervenimos en la educación el primero
por supuesto el profesor y es el que
todos conocemos es el la persona
encargada digamos el docente profesional
el que ha estudiado y se ha
especializado y el que finalmente es la
persona que comunica a los estudiantes
su conocimiento ese es tal vez el
reflejo más elemental de quien enseña y
cómo se enseña el segundo tiene que ver
con toda la reglamentación y es que si
bien ese docente puede tener unas ideas
particulares al final lo que es cierto
es que estamos en un establecimiento en
el caso colombiano el ministerio de
educación que es el que finalmente regla
cuántos años vamos a un colegio que
vamos a estudiar qué competencias
desarrollamos
y esas competencias que se desarrollan a
través digamos de esa reglamentación
general finalmente están enmarcadas no
solo en la condición del ministerio
dedicación sino en los elementos o
estamentos a los cuales colombia
pertenece en este caso la ocde y
mencionó la hoy de por qué la hoy ha
estado muy interesada en el tema de la
competencia y la calidad de la educación
en sus países miembros y de ahí se
deriva la prueba pisa la prueba pisa
básicamente es una prueba que lo que
hace es testear es un programa
internacional que lo que revisa es la
condición de los niveles de educación en
los diferentes países para que con eso
se pueda convertir en un referente
internacional e inclusive contribuya
pues a una condición de mejora entonces
esos resultados lo que brindan es la
capacidad para una reflexión comparativa
para que los países puedan de ahí
digamos a ser implementaciones y mejoras
qué es lo que básicamente la prueba pisa
nos enseñó lo que está conduciendo a
mirar en el caso particular es lectura
matemáticas y ciencias básicamente esas
son las tres niveles que miran
y quienes participan de esta prueba pues
básicamente los que participan son los
países de la ocde más otros países que
intervienen no necesariamente estando en
la óptima
entonces digamos que lo que vemos ahí es
que más o menos en el último periodo que
se hizo la prueba porque no es anual en
el 2018 fue la última prueba que se hizo
básicamente participaron 79 países que
se reflejan digamos un poco en este
gráfico unos países de la ocde otros
países no ocde y finalmente estos países
no te varían dependiendo digamos de la
condición del examen hay a veces unos a
veces otros pero de carácter relevante y
la razón por la cual muestro este examen
es porque me interesa situarnos un poco
en ese examen entonces a quienes les va
muy bien en ese examen pues aquí están
los resultados y aquí va más hay un dato
curioso porque aunque china está de
primera en esa lista no es china general
sino es una región particular de china
que fue la que tomó la prueba porque no
fue todo el país completo el que tomó la
prueba sino fue una región específica de
unas ciudades específicas que además que
tomar la prueba pero si bien es cierto
en este listado encontramos sobre todo
naciones digamos en
rápido proceso de desarrollo o
desarrolladas
me interesa quedan un poco como colombia
está en esa condición o como se compara
digamos dentro este grupo nosotros
quedamos en la posición número 56 en el
2018 esta posición 56 lo que nos sitúa
es en el último cuarto de las escalas de
círculo tres cuartos del grupo de países
que hicieron un tuvieron un mejor
resultado en estas pruebas pisa y
colombia estaba en un umbral en el cual
si bien en latinoamérica estamos como en
la mitad hay países como por ejemplo
méxico el chile que están por encima a
nosotros pero también hay países como
por ejemplo pero que están por debajo a
nosotros pero lo interesante digamos de
estos resultados es cómo nos comparamos
y cómo nos vemos y qué aprendemos de lo
que estamos viendo ahí una de las cosas
que estamos viendo aquí la línea de
color morado es el promedio de los de
los todos los países de la ocde la línea
color azul clara es los no ocde y la
línea roja es colombia y la línea verde
es latinoamérica entonces que esto que
nos muestra que colombia arrancó estando
por debajo del promedio de latinoamérica
y que en los últimos años ha repuntado
ya ha podido pasar un poquito el
promedio latinoamericano pero lo que nos
muestra que es más preocupante es que
efectivamente latinoamérica está en el
rango bajo o sea no sólo somos nosotros
como como países lados sino como región
que tenemos un desafío hacia la
educación y aquí están los diferentes
dominios por ejemplo el caso la
matemática se comporta exactamente igual
en el caso de las ciencias se comporta
exactamente igual
después otra variable que es relevante y
es
cómo se clasifican según los
establecimientos educativos y qué
resultado se obtiene entonces aquí está
los rurales los oficiales y los privados
y algo obvio y aquí lo vemos en estos
gráficos es que efectivamente los
colegios que logran el mejor nivel son
los privados después siguen los
oficiales y por último los regulares
esto pues no nos sorprende yo creo que
es todo todo lo tenemos muy claro pero
lo que es cierto dentro de esta
condición es que en todo caso comparado
con el último cuadro estamos por debajo
de los productos promedios entonces si
bien es una regla general que en el
mundo entero los privados los que los
privados son brindar la mejor calidad
educación los públicos la segunda y los
rurales la menos buena
en ese sentido digamos que respondemos a
una radiografía similar a la del mundo
es un tema y es un desafío que tiene
digamos el planeta y la educación
general en el mundo y claro no entiende
porque esa educación es tan difícil de
lograr en los ámbitos rurales esto es un
caso que se hizo famoso de una niña que
atendía a clases subiéndose a un árbol
para que el árbol lograra con el celular
capturar la señal de internet y
obviamente es imposible que personas que
en estas condiciones logren un nivel de
desarrollo educativo como se logra
digamos en las grandes ciudades entonces
de aquí parte de una una reflexión sobre
estos resultados de la prueba pisa y es
obviamente la dificultad de la
estandarización de un examen
y finalmente si somos diferentes somos
colombianos somos latinos no somos
anglosajones este es un examen con
digamos que ha sido conducido por los
países anglosajones en su base entonces
obviamente están hablando unas
fortalezas que no necesariamente son las
habilidades de la mayor fortaleza en los
contextos latinos y claro que otros
elementos quedaron por fuera pues por
supuesto las humanidades quedó por fuera
la comunicación quedó por fuera las
artes la danza la música
el territorio el universo porque
finalmente cada territorio diferente y
particular y por supuesto la familia que
es algo que es curioso que uno lo
mencioné en los ámbitos de la educación
pero es que es algo que realmente
finalmente de la familia es la familia
la primera fuente de educación que
recibimos todos
entonces de aquí me emigró al tercer
profesor que es la arquitectura que es
nuestro argumento y finalmente esta
arquitectura es la que hace un entorno
que nos influencia nos motiva o nos
desmotiva nos ayuda o no nos ayuda o
yeste esta fotografía es dramática
porque finalmente aquí ni siquiera haya
arquitectura sino que lo único que hay
es unos muebles pero expresa un poco el
desafío que tenemos desde una situación
de educación base digamos elemental sin
casi instrumentos hasta una condición en
la cual podemos dar digamos y
estructurar cosas de mucha mayor
envergadura entonces la pregunta
genérica es como la arquitectura de
alguna manera influye en el rendimiento
en el aprendizaje de manera positiva o
negativa y la pregunta asociada a esto
por supuesto cuáles son los valores
agregados que se deberían otorgar al
espacio para que logremos un impacto
positivo y dentro de eso entonces hago
un decálogo son básicamente 10 puntos
que son nuestras recomendaciones como
arquitectos que en los cuales hemos
venido trabajando en los colegios que
hemos venido trabajando nos mostraron
una secuencia algunas imágenes del
proyecto que hemos hecho en diferentes
colegios pero que lo que siguen es esta
condición de decálogo
lo primero es piensa en el todo o sea el
plasma esto es fundamental que las
instituciones educativas que se hacen
poco a poco y en el tiempo que se toman
más de una década muchas veces cinco o
seis décadas construyendo se tengan la
idea de proyectarse a futuro eso es lo
que hace un plan maestro revisa cómo nos
vamos a ver a futuro y cómo podemos
tomar decisiones parciales para vernos a
futuro el otro tema es el verde la idea
de campus porque finalmente si bien la
clase pasa en un edificio la relación de
entre hombre entre hombres naturaleza y
edificación es fundamental entonces aquí
en el caso particular digamos del anglo
lo que hemos cuidado es que el campus
tenga un buen balance entre lo que se
construyó lo que no se construye y el
aporte del verde comunitario realidad y
parte de la educación y esto es un
reflejo que puede verse o como una idea
campus general o comunidad que el
edificio captura para que ese espacio
central tenga un área de extensión o que
se puede inclusive como el edificio en
sí mismo puede tener esa condición de
verte
espacios de extinción para el
aprendizaje y es que había otro
argumento importantísimo y la valoración
de la educación no formal verso la
formal la formal digamos que es el aula
clase la no formal es la no habla de
clase lo que hacemos en los corredores
al encontrarnos al salir del aula de
clase esa educación es súper importante
porque finalmente estamos recibiendo
inputs de ambas y con ambas es que nos
estamos formando entonces esas áreas
comunes tienen un enorme valor en la
edificación en el caso de encontrarnos
de poder hacer otra serie de cosas de
tomar decisiones de socializar y por eso
estas áreas de extensión para los
aprendizajes son importantísimas y hemos
hecho un gran esfuerzo para que estas
áreas además convoquen no solamente a
que los estudiantes se encuentren sino a
que los profesores puedan trabajar en
grupo a que los estudiantes tienen otras
dinámicas porque el tamaño de ese
espacio es mayor etcétera ese es un
espacio de oportunidad de formación
tanto formal como informal el confort y
la salud humana visto es un tema súper
actual nos tenemos que vivir espacios
que sean confortables con respecto a las
respecto a las a la acústica
con respecto a la iluminación con
respecto a la ventilación etcétera y
estos espacios personalmente lo que
permiten es un buen entorno de enseñanza
y aprendizaje estos espacios hoy por hoy
y las factores operativos de su espacio
es cobran más valor y eso no lo ha
demostrado la pandemia es importante que
un espacio ventile y es un espacio que
el espacio esté iluminado el otro tema
digamos que valoramos y que trabajamos
mucho es el tema de la flexibilidad los
espacios multiuso porque la inversión se
hace una vez pero tenemos que dar el
valor que más se pueda y el uso que más
se pueda en ese sentido una cafetería
puede ser más que una cafetería puede
convertirse también un auditorio y se
logran sencillamente cerrando unas
puertas en la cual se divide la cocina
digamos con la parte del auditorio esa
es una de las estrategias hay otras
estrategias como el hecho de que un
espacio pueda digamos revertirse hacia
el exterior es el revestimiento hacia el
exterior del espacio lo que ayuda en
esencia es a que el espacio tenga una
condición de fluidez hacia el interior y
hacia el exterior y una capilla pueda
convertirse por ejemplo en un escenario
para los eventos de cierre de uno y
estas ideas que digamos nacen en las
esencias de estos colegios también las
hemos podido digamos llevar a otras
dimensiones en otros lugares y en otras
condiciones o sea la semilla de la idea
finalmente en abstracto se replica en
cualquier sitio
la arquitectura como recurso pedagógico
ese es un tema fundamental los edificios
son más que edificios es decir el
edificio cumple su rol de y su labor
pero finalmente dentro del edificio se
pueden hacer actividades que tienen que
ver con la naturaleza el edificio en
este caso unos estudiantes aprendiendo
sobre el renacimiento está la clase
sobre el estudio del renacimiento de
carece del renacimiento de la
perspectiva todo lo que hacen es
trabajos con el edificio para que el
estudiante pueda entender la perspectiva
el autorretrato y entender de qué se
trata el renacimiento
cero emisiones pues eso es una ideal que
estamos persiguiendo hoy en día todos
los arquitectos y en general digamos el
mundo entero eso es un desafío gigante
hemos hecho
colegios os recomendamos que los
colegios sean muy sensibles con el uso
del agua con el manejo obviamente
electricidad etcétera y en algunos casos
como este caso que estoy mostrando hay
certificaciones internacionales
digamos que básicamente validan que eso
se ha hecho y al final es un tema no
solo de ser certificado sino es un tema
de conciencia y necesidad en la
arquitectura que permita su desarrollo
en el tiempo esto es fundamental es
porque si bien lo que decía con respecto
al plasma de esto se hace un edificio
tras otro inclusive hay veces que el
edificio ni siquiera se puede hacer
completo entonces hemos tenido
situaciones en las cuales a través de
valorar un módulo y repetir el módulo
podemos lograr que el edificio crezca en
el tiempo de espacio al ritmo de la
inversión que tenga disponible el
colegio y al ritmo del crecimiento en el
tamaño poblacional del colegio y esto es
en este caso donde este módulo se
replica pero lo que es interesante es
que en su proceso intermedio en sus
varias etapas nunca se ve como un
edificio no terminado siempre sede un
edificio terminado que va creciendo poco
a poco con estos sistemas
los que se van ampliando
el valor de lo local lo global y lo
local lo local logro al versus lo local
es un tema que cada vez coja más fuerza
somos seres universales pero al mismo
tiempo tenemos una cantidad de patrones
locales que nos dan información y que
nos sirven para hacer espacios
emocionantes en este caso un ejemplo y
es el caney de la región de santander
que nos sirve para hacer un edificio
educativo de gran formato es a base de
un elemento que se usaba para secar
tabaco como al reescalar la y
reconvertir la labor vemos en un
edificio contemporáneo que no sólo
valorar retomar esa arquitectura y
reinterpretarla sino que además valora
el lugar donde está puesto de la forma
como se visualiza el paisaje
y por último la belleza el famoso
venustas que viene digamos desde la base
griega y es que si la arquitectura puede
ser bella y debe ser bella y entonces
esta idea de que en las columnas en el
caso de una obra como el partenón
se pueden
interpretar y volver otro tipo de
columnas y dándole una belleza
particular y única y esa belleza es no
sólo está asociada a la arquitectura en
su gran formato está asociada al detalle
que tiene la arquitectura o sea la
belleza tiene que estar en el grande y
en el pequeño en el detalle tiene que
estar en todo y por eso una escalera
puede ser un poco más que una escalera
un edificio laboratorios puede ser más
que un ente lo que entendemos de un
edificio de laboratorios un edificio
puede tener una imagen y una apariencia
que lo que esté transmitiendo es esa
condición de belleza y atractivo
al final de éste tercer profesor lo que
puede y debe es generar un mejor entorno
para el aprendizaje que al final es esa
es la apuesta y eso es digamos el valor
de ese tercer profesor en la
arquitectura escolar para el aprendizaje
obviamente también para la tolerancia
para la comunicación para la empatía
para el trabajo en equipo para disfrutar
para para muchas cosas o sea
y todo eso para que sea pues
sencillamente para un propósito mucho
mayor o sea eso es una contribución que
desde la óptica digamos de construir
infraestructura para sistemas educativos
se puede aportar pero finalmente para un
propósito mayor que es este y es el
desafío enorme que tenemos estamos somos
más de 7500 millones de habitantes en el
planeta tierra las proyecciones es que
va a seguir creciendo vamos a llegar
fácilmente a un 10 mil 511 mil pero el
planeta no crece entonces tenemos un
enorme desafío eso es lo que viene ese
es un desafío gigante y también ese es
parte del desafío que estamos viviendo
hoy la dificultad de comunicarnos la
incapacidad de podernos asociar y
entender finalmente ese tercer profesor
lo que tiene que contribuir es a generar
un mejor entorno para vivir para que
podamos de alguna manera comunicarnos
mejor tolerarnos y generar un mundo
mejor para vivir gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]